foreign
Jacob is in Elizabeth City North
Carolina hi Jacob welcome to the Ramsey
Show
thanks Steve I am calling because my
wife and I are in baby steps three and
we just found out that on her van needs
a new transmission and the cost for the
repairs is going to drain what we have
currently in our emergency fund so I say
go ahead and do it that's what the
emergency funds for let's get the van
fixed and always how much is it going to
cost to fix the van
so it was going to be 4 500 including
labor
and that's your whole three to six
months of emergencies fund no no we're
in baby step three okay so we haven't
completed it yet okay I see yeah we have
four thousand dollars so far so it would
be a three thousand dollar deposit and
then we could get towed at five hundred
dollars I mean the other five hundred
dollars to fix it what year is this man
okay or something what year is it 2005
what's it worth
um I'm not sure I'm gonna look because
we haven't been looking to sell or
anything but it's a Honda Odyssey was
only like 160 000 miles on it
okay
um the first thing I'm always going to
do with transmissions and engines
is um you real is this is like um the
car has cancer you don't go with one you
get multiple opinions you need a second
opinion and a third opinion not
necessarily does the transmission need
to be replaced but is there a more
economical way to get this transmission
replaced who gave you this bid the
dealer
no it's a local mechanic that's good so
we've been going through for a couple
years we trust them I trust him too
it doesn't sound outlandish but it is a
big enough expense I want you to get
some other opinions and uh I'm guessing
you have two cars right and this is one
of them
yeah so we have that her van and then I
have a 1998 Honda Accord with like 205
000 miles on it what's your household
um I make I have like a base of 60 and
then I get bonus on top of that so A
basically
60 000. Oh 60. I thought you said 16. I
did too okay I feel better already
um yeah me too okay so yeah yeah yeah
you fix the van that's what the
emergency fund's for
okay that's what I figured but I am
going to get a couple of bits not just
the one mechanic that I trust uh and it
may lead you right back to him and I
kind of think it's going to and that's
okay but you want you just want to uh in
the in the multitude of counsel there is
safety the Bible says where there are
options lots of options you will choose
a better choice than when you have only
one option
or only two options so I'm gonna go talk
to two or three other people figure out
is there a more economical reasonable
way that the that is reliable to get
this transmission replaced I doubt it
um I I don't think that's a bad price
off the top of my head but hey man you
might find somebody do it for 3 500 and
be worth looking I'm also wondering what
that van was worth
um it's Honda Odyssey they're oh five a
wee bit pricey so